Hello everyone. Just getting everybody admitted here. Okay. I think everybody has been entered.
I'll share the screen here. All right. Happy Monday everyone. Hope everybody had a good weekend.
We're back at it with the Monday Zoom call. So we will start right in.
All right. So the first question is regarding Fenn Bend is all. I have a monthly supply. How long will I need to take this? What kind of parasites do I have specifically what can I expect to feel like when purging this? How will I know when it's all out? Okay. So first, when we are making our recommendations, we're looking at causes of a, you know, a reason why
somebody has a diagnosis addressing that and then we're also looking at cancer balancers. So a lot of times the Fenn Bend is all product will come up as a cancer balancer. So it doesn't necessarily mean that we are using it to to attack parasites. So certainly sometimes biotoxins will come up as part of a cause and if Fenn Bend is all is helping in that case, then
it is probably a parasite that we're dealing with. In this case for this person, the Fenn Bend is all is coming up as a cancer balancer. So that's how we're using it to help help with cancer. So a side effect of using it could be that it could be killing off some parasites, you know, a good side effect of that.
Most of us do have some type of parasite and, you know, do need to get rid of that. So once in a while, you know, regardless of cancer or not, it sometimes is good to just do a parasite cleanse a couple times a year to just kind of clean the system.
But again, for this case, we're using the product as a cancer balancer. So you might not have any parasites that need to come out, you might, you would, we're not saying you have a specific parasite at all because this is coming up as a cancer balancer.
So what can I expect to feel like when purging this? So if when you start it, you do end up purging some parasites.
It might just feel like a sudden urge to use the restroom.
It might not, you know, produce anything if, you know, again, parasites are not, you know, being attacked or released from the bodies, you might not have any side effect at all.
And how do I know it's all out? Well, if you are, you know, expelling some parasites, you'll just keep expelling them and who I don't know how long it will take.
Sometimes it takes a very long time. Sometimes people are getting rid of parasites for, for a very long time. So, so I don't know there's no direct answer to that.
But again, for this case, we're using it as a cancer balancer. So it's not for parasite purposes.
All right, so the coffee animals, this is another mental hurdle, which I think I'm closer to resolving slow adapter here, adapter, just need to get over my fear.
So yes, a lot of times it is a very foreign thing to, you know, think about, you know, coffee animals. And so if you're not used to it, yeah, it takes a while and you might have to do some more research, you know, work up the courage sounds like this person is almost there.
You know, I think we had originally recommended some coffee animals and then reiterated with genetic information that coffee animals might be a good thing.
Certainly there's other things you can do. If you really are just not going to do coffee animals, other things that we can do to help with detoxification.
Caster oil packs certainly supplements, you know, really everything that we're doing has a component of detoxing the body.
So coffee animals are just a great way to help encourage that. And they stimulate the parasympathetic branch of the nervous system.
So there's, there's other benefits in addition to the detoxing process. So yes, you know, I don't have any specific advice to kind of getting over the mental block of doing it other than just equipping yourself with information and getting familiar with it, giving yourself grace.
You know, if you do work up enough courage to try it, if it doesn't go the way that you planned, you know, don't get frustrated, your body does need to get used to it.
Search on the membership site or look on the membership site for the lazy man's way of doing a coffee animal.
You know, the information in your binder regarding coffee animals is kind of the preferred way, but Dr. Connors has kind of the easy way to do it. You might want to start there.
So just, you know, start, just start somewhere and eventually you'll get there and you might end up loving it. A lot of times patients are like, oh my gosh, I don't understand when I was so afraid of, you know, that I actually felt so much better after doing a coffee animal. So just think of the positives.
Otherwise, she is doing well with the supplements tolerating things nicely had some scans recently and showed lungs and liver are improving blood work has also improved praise the Lord. Yes, absolutely praise the Lord. Thank you for sending that in. We love to hear the successes. So we are celebrating with you. That's wonderful.
Okay, some more questions on coffee animals are coffee animals good if you use decaf coffee. So they will still be good.
But as far as a detoxification component, they decaf coffee is not quite as good as using the caffeinated coffee.
There are specific components in in the caffeine that help to dilate or the caffeine helps to dilate the liver biodex and this helps us to get rid of toxins. It really allows a toxin that are stored within the liver to be dumped with bile through the biodex.
You know, into the digestive tract, so you're eliminating things through the toilet. So the that caffeine helps in the dilation process of those liver biodex.
So using a decafinated coffee would not be as good as using the caffeinated version for that reason.
And then also the paulmetic acids. So there's some components in coffee that when you are going through the decaffeination process, some of these components are removed.
Maybe not completely, but removed. And this is the active component that we want for the coffee animal and for the detoxification and the blood purification purposes, so stimulating the, you know, the gene that produces the glutathione for detoxification.
So the decaf process will remove some of those. The other thing with decaffeinated coffee is the conventional process to decaffeinating the beans is a toxic process. They're typically using highly toxic solvents to decaffeinated coffee.
So if you are going to use a decaffeinated coffee, I would advise you to look for a decaffe coffee. And this is true if you're drinking it as well.
So you want to look for decaffeinated coffees that use a specific process. It's called a Swiss water process.
So it's a way of decaffeinating the beans that doesn't use the toxic solvents. So again, that's the Swiss water process. So look for that if you're going to be drinking cafe decaffeinated coffee, or if you are going to use decaffeinated coffee in your coffee animals, because really we don't want those toxins for trying to get rid of toxins.
So, okay. And then let's see. I think there was something else that I wanted to say, oh, yes. And as far as, you know, the purpose of using a decaffe coffee for coffee animals, I'm assuming is because you don't want that stimulating effect from the caffeine.
And really, it is a different process. It's a different kind of mechanism of metabolism when you're doing a coffee animal versus drinking a cup of coffee.
So you are not going to get as much of a stimulating effect from the caffeine when you're doing a coffee animal. You'll still absorb some of that caffeine.
But really, the caffeine is going directly to the liver and, you know, stimulating, like we mentioned, those biodex to open and helping with the blood purification and the detoxing process, but you're not going to get or you shouldn't get such a stimulating effect as you would if you were drinking it.
So I don't know if that's the reason that you wanted to use decaffe. Maybe you have used regular coffee for coffee animals. And you do get really jittery from it. You might be really sensitive to caffeine. So certainly you can try using decaffe. And you will still be getting the benefits of stimulating the parasympathetic branch of the nervous system.
You know, whether you're using regular coffee, decaffe, or if you're just using water, water, animal, or camel meal, animal, probiotic, animal. So it's just the animal itself that is helping to stimulate the vagus nerve to boost the parasympathetic branch of the nervous system.
So I guess that was a long answer to this question, and it kind of depends on, you know, what you're looking for. And but at the end of the day using the caffeine for a coffee animal does have some additional benefits versus using decaffe.
Okay, next question. Again, coffee animals. So it's coffee animal Monday. I'm having a hard time holding the full amount of coffee animal. Is it effective to do just half of the coffee and then do the other half right away. Yes, that would be fine. Another option would maybe just to be.
Just be using less water. So you can still use the same amount of coffee, just make it more concentrated, use less water. And then, you know, hold, you know, do what you can with half that amount more concentrated version and, you know, maybe you can
hold it for that full amount instead of having to do it twice.
So you can try that. That's certainly you can do it, do it twice. And that would be fine. Okay, does anyone have any suggestions for getting the smoothie down. It's a dreaded part of the day no matter what the flavor I've tried.
So yes, really, I guess the first thing I would say is if you can try to identify what part of the smoothie is the part that's making it taste bad. So, you know, a lot of times the greens first product is in your smoothie recommendations sometimes there's mushrooms.
There's, you know, vitamin C or there's corset and there's sun spectrum. So some of these things have a very neutral flavor and probably aren't what is contributing to your dislike of the taste. So if you can identify what it is, I would assume if there's mushrooms in your mix, then it might be the mushrooms.
You can always take anything that's powdered and capitalize it and just take it, you know, as a pill. So that is an option.
There is an option if it is the greens first flavor, you know, that you don't like. There is we do have greens first capsules.
And the deal with that you can order the capsules off our web store. You just have to take six of them to equal one scoop of the greens first powder.
But certainly an option. So try to identify what it is that's making it taste awful to you and see if you can capitalize that take it as a pill.
Otherwise, just trying different combinations, you know, you can add different fruits, you know, different vegetables to try to change the flavor.
Maybe you've already tried that and it's still not working. So I guess my suggestion would be to try to capitalize whatever component is making it not taste good and get it in that way.
Somebody else has suggestions as to what they have done to help make the smoothie go down more easily.
Chat those in. Let us know.
All right. I submitted a question about relief from back pain and I need to clarify that it isn't really just back pain, but a pain in my inner core is the best way I can describe it.
It would be something to give me relief from this constant pain that would be great.
So yes, so pain is something that we many of our patients are dealing with chronic pain, you know, whether it is pain from the cancer itself, or it's pain from a therapy, or, you know, whatever it is, you know, could be referred pain of some sort.
So the first thing is to really kind of try to identify what the pain is from.
And, and yes, there are natural things that can help with pain, but unfortunately, there's not really anything from a natural perspective that really knocks pain down like a prescription medication.
And sometimes, you know, when all efforts fail from a natural perspective, it is okay to, you know, check in with your general practitioner or your oncologist and give a prescription for some pain medication because that pain cycle is, you can be so hard to, you know, to break that pain cycle.
And it really just sends those stress signals throughout the body. We know we don't heal when we're in that constant state of stress.
So we have to do it. We can to get over pain so we can, you know, be in a more relaxed state so that the body can heal, but there's tons of information on our website about pain.
So I've referenced this before there is a blog post that Dr. Conners goes into detail about good pain and bad pain because pain is not always a bad thing, but certainly when when it's chronic or intense, we need to manage that things you can do from a natural perspective.
There's supplements, so curcumin, Boswellia, clear and flam is, you know, a nice mixture of different herbs that have been scientifically shown to help kind of break that pain cycle, you can try that.
The limit list is another product that there's been a lot of good reports for it, helping with the pain cycle on CBD, THC and marijuana. So that's really probably the strongest thing from a natural perspective to address pain is THC and marijuana.
So, you know, depending on what state you live in, you'll have to kind of figure out the the hoops that you need to jump through to get that, but that can certainly help and coffee animals can help with pain as well because they are stimulating the vagus nerve pushing that parasympathetic branch of the nervous system, which can minimize pain and you can do multiple coffee animals in a day to help attack pain.
There's also rife programs for pain and you know, I wish there was one quick easy thing that I could suggest for someone to help relieve constant pain, but there just really isn't everybody is different.
And so you have to just try different things and see if you can get ahead of it, see if you can manage it with some of these natural things and if it's just too intense and you know constant then like I said, don't feel bad checking in with your general practitioner to see if you can get a medication doesn't mean you're going to have to be on it forever.
It just means we need to get over this hump and if we can, you know, just kind of jump this hurdle, get you in a better position, you know, you potentially can come off that medication and and be okay, but we do have to manage that pain.
Hopefully this helps and certainly do a blog search if you just type in the word pain there's going to be a lot of information on our website regarding tips to help with pain.
Alright, I am wondering about the iron tonics should I continue to take that to I have, I have been but there doesn't seem to be any changes in the energy level or my stamina don't mean to be negative, but between not having the energy level losing my strength.
This person's getting some bleeding and the skin is fragile some stomach issues he's having some low moments understandably praying for some help with the answers to help me know when things may change for the better.
Yes, so this person is we're trying to work through some anemia and you know doing yeah he's getting kind of regular lab work things like that.
So we made the suggestion of trying the iron tonic and as we've talked about in many of these zoom calls kind of the issue with iron and you know it kind of puts us in this dilemma because iron can be a fuel for cancer, but obviously we cannot.
Let levels of iron get low because it starts affecting our quality of life and how we feel and and we can't live with without iron so we need iron, but you know when there's cancer it's just kind of this catch 22 so when we're feeling these symptoms as this person is describing we do need to.
You know address it so we're trying the iron tonic and then anytime we do give iron we are coupling it with some cancer fighting things because again if the iron is being used as fuel for the cancer.
We want to make sure we're getting those cancer fighting supplements that piggyback along with iron so it's up taking some of the cancer fighting supplements as well.
So all of that being said yes he should continue to take the iron tonic you know really until we have another lab report seeing if it is showing any benefit now he's saying he doesn't see any any changes in his energy level or stamina, but maybe it's not getting worse maybe it hasn't increased but maybe it's not getting worse so maybe we are.
We are you know helping even though it doesn't feel like it's we really want you to stay on it until we're getting blood work done to see where your levels are at and then we can make another you know reassessment with what we're doing and you know you might have to do an iron infusion or something like that so.
So we just have to take it kind of day by day and certainly it can be you know can bring you down when you don't have energy it really brings you down obviously physically but mentally and emotionally as well so just know that we are praying for you we're doing everything that we can within our scope you know to try and help with the rife and blood building.
Programming programs on the rife and with iron the iron protocols and cancer fighters so so we're doing everything that we can and we just have to take it one day at a time certainly prayer and you know you might need to enlist some help with the general practitioner as well and you might need to do an iron infusion.
Alright, can I eat Zekeiel bread kiwi bison wild ground puff mushrooms from our neighbors yard and no pesticides that sounds great.
Yes, so really we want to refer you back to your binder and your dietary recommendations so really with a Zekeiel bread so it's just you know a great whole grain source it does have some gluten in it so you need to be a little bit careful if gluten is something that is feeding your cancer but.
A lot of times that's not the case and so limited amounts of gluten would be fine Zekeiel bread like I said is a great source of whole grains and so there's going to be a lot of fiber so it is a great choice if you're eating bread and if you can have a little bit of gluten so that's fine kiwi is absolutely fine.
You know I would indeed 12 kiwi in a day but certainly kiwi here and there is just fine bison so again referring back to your diet if we have told you that you need to avoid red meat then you know I would say no to bison but if you are able to eat red meat then bison is a great source that would be just fine if we've asked you to limit red meat.
Then certainly kind of adhere to that those guidelines and recommendations and if you you know we're just recommending you have it a couple times a month then certainly bison can be your thing for those few times a month when you are eating red meat and I don't see any issues or problems with wild grown puff mushrooms that are pesticide free that sounds great.
Okay, oh and here's one it's not really a zoom call question but I thought it would be good to just put it in here so we can you know just as a little reminder so somebody sent did send a question saying that there's zoom ID number does not work anymore and tried to follow the instructions given but was not successful so the best way to jump on to these zoom calls is through the membership site and clicking on the.
button that says join the call so there is a button that says register for the call so obviously people have registered and that's fine but there is another button that will allow you to link directly to the call at the time of the call so my suggestion is just always try to use that button because sometimes we do have to change the zoom information and it changes that meeting ID so obviously we did that recently most of you know.
And so if you had just copied the meeting ID and you're just entering that yes it did change so it doesn't work work anymore so connect through that link and and then you'll always have access through the current meeting ID number and we don't change them you know at least we have not changed the meeting ID number.
You know in any regular fashion but we might be doing that once in a while you know at least a little more regularly just to keep things updated and so it is good again to just kind of connect through through the membership page.
membership page.
Especially now since there's a lot will not a lot but there's more zoom calls and so there's multiple meeting ID numbers that you would need to be saving and then if they change you need to change them all so again just join through the membership site and you'll have access to the current meetings and the current ID numbers.
So that was all of the questions that had come in so now there's a couple chat questions that come in had come in let's see.
Coffee animals the number one thing I hate to love but love them I do pro tips start with one cup warm water you hold just till you have to go then do the coffee.
This helped me tons okay so that is a great tip thank you yes if anybody has tips or things that have really helped them and absolutely send them in so thank you for sending that so one cup of warm water to just start with and then do the coffee so that has helped this person so some good good advice.
Okay I am not able to get into the zoom call from the membership page it never recognizes my email or password I have to use the email you sent me okay um it never recognizes my email or password I am not sure so previously um I think you were able to connect to zoom calls without.
Without you know kind of registering an email address or something now we've made it mandatory for you to register for them and we did that because we were having this just major confusion with the way people were identified to us in the calls so names were coming up as.
Staff members so you know there would be two Angie Helgisins on the call and you know obviously and she wasn't on the call but somebody was logged in her two people with her name or.
Same thing with Dr Conner's name is coming up and well I know Dr Conner's it has got appointment scheduled and he's not on my zoom call you know he could be but I know he wasn't but his name is coming up so.
So that's why we made it mandatory for you to register so it is requiring you to have an individual zoom account you have to put in your name so we know who's on the call um you know just for identification purposes and I don't know if that is causing a blip and people logging on.
You know so it is your zoom your zoom account so your zoom email address and your zoom password to get into your zoom account and then it links you to our zoom call so i'm not quite sure i'm not able to get into the zoom call from the membership page.
Yeah, I don't know maybe I have to bring that to Dustin and he can kind of see if there's an issue there, but that would be my only thing is you know just make sure you're logging in through your zoom account and you have that active and you know your password and everything for your zoom account and then it links to to our calls so.
Okay, any other questions, so I know somebody just logged in and we've kind of gone through all the questions that came in and we just finished up some of the chat questions so.
This is being recorded so I will be posting this on the membership site just shortly after we're all done here, so it will be posted momentarily so you certainly can go back and listen to the recording I know you had a question and I did answer that question so you can listen to the recording okay let's see here this is new somebody raised their hand.
I do not know what that means or how to what to do when somebody raises their hand certainly you can send in a chat if you have a question or.
Can you hear me I can oh okay good I raise on the person who raised okay thank you no problem, I have.
I have a question about the drug that was mentioned early the Fennbenza so yes the Fennbenza so yes the question has to do with is that something that is prescribed by medical like oncologist and if so what what is it used for because the fact that you all would recommend it.
It could possibly be obviously you've done your research and it does whatever you expected to do so i'm just wondering what the on the oncologist use it is you know i'm not sure.
Tantus they use it for maybe can help me out yes so Fennbenza is not a prescription medication it is an over the counter product that typically is being used by veterinarians as a D warming.
So it's helping to get rid of parasites or or worms there is i'm so somebody I don't know if you've ever heard of a person named Joe tippens but in the recent years Joe tippens has gotten a lot of.
I guess press yeah attention in the natural alternative you know therapies for cancer because he used a specific protocol and cured himself from cancer so if you did a search for the Joe tippens protocol you would be able to learn all about him his story and you know how he came about this protocol and how it helped him.
And this protocol you know has since like I mentioned become very popular so we use the protocol.
And it's not just the Fennbenza it's also three other products it's a curcumin or a tumor product it's also a vitamin E product and then a CBD product so that's kind of the whole protocol.
And so we use this in our testing so we'll test people to see if this comes up as a cancer balancer for them either the complete protocol or sometimes it's just a portion of it sometimes it's just the Fennbenza product that comes up as a cancer balancer so yeah so we do test people for it.
And if we have not recommended it it is because it didn't test as a cancer balancer but a lot of times patients initiate the Fennbenza or the Joe tippens protocol on their own certainly you can look into that if you want to learn more about it or if you feel compelled to try it it has helped a lot of people so I would again do a search for the Joe tippens protocol you can also look on our way.
The type store if you type in Joe tippens and it will bring up you know the protocol and our products and so you can kind of learn about it that way perfect thank you so much well you're very welcome.
Oh hey there is another chat that came in it seems overwhelming with 40 plus supplements each morning and more in the afternoon and evening can I add can I add supplements empty the capsules to my daily.
Drink if so which one and how many so yes absolutely you can empty supplements into into your drink or smoothie and it's not a hard science it's not a black and white rule yes this one's no this one so you might have to just play with that you know so I can I don't know.
There's no right or wrong answer to which ones and how many you can just start by trying one out of time and seeing if it you know changes the flavor of what you're consuming if it makes it something that you just cannot stand that one might be better to take as a capsule so yeah you can play with it and yes it does get overwhelming with a lot of supplements many times patients use a pulsing method.
With supplements a lot of times patients are taking supplements outside of what we have recommended and so there may be pulsing those supplements by pulsing I mean taking supplements on a rotational basis so you know if you're taking seven things from us you know that we really want you to take according to how we're asking you to take them but then you've got 10 other supplements that you're using.
Because oh I you know I read this helps or this makes me feel better I get energy from this so there's value to taking other supplements if they are helping you and we don't want to take those away if unless we've indicated no don't take these then there's a specific ingredient that we don't want you to take which we we've indicated but if you're taking additional supplements and you feel like I'm just taking so many you can pulse them so out of those 10 extra ones
that you have maybe take you know five of them one week or for two weeks and then you know rotate them out and take the next five and take them for a week or two weeks and so you're not taking all of them you know on a daily basis but you're still getting getting them in the system just on a rotational basis so you can try that and you absolutely can empty capsules into drinks and that would be fine.
Just try one at a time to see which ones you know our taller rolls as far as your palate and and go from there so I hope that helps any other questions okay if we decide to start something new on our own should we run those by you or only when we send in a cheek swab so if you do decide to try something new it is good to just you know
shoot us an email and you know and we can look at the ingredients and let you know oh we really don't want you to take this because you know of this form of the B vitamin that's in there or it has copper or that's not the best form of something so it is good to run it by us
and and then we also have it in your notes on on what you're taking so that when we do follow up with a cheek swab we have it noted in there that you are taking an additional supplement all right
okay I agree coffee animals now are one of my favorite healing modalities it was not something I enjoyed in the beginning but now my day is not complete unless I do one try to have a bowel movement before you start if you can I also agree with the water flush I do a full court to remove extra feces prior to the coffee this makes holding the coffee so much easier
also relax and pray do breath work etc while holding the coffee this helps with any tension I always feel lighter and have reduced pain afterwards you can do this wonderful that is really encouraging and thank you for sending that in so that's great great advice
yes we need to support each other and cheer each other on so hopefully this helped and this person can get past their fear and and do a coffee anima and hopefully she'll have the same positive response you can let us know how it goes all right to any other questions
don't see any other questions coming and all right everyone I guess we will wrap it up thank you for sending in your great questions I always learn from your guys's questions and I hope that you know you guys are learning and learning from each other as well
so continue to send in those questions and we will do the best we can to support you and get these answered for you
all right we'll have a wonderful rest of your day looking forward to well next Monday I think it's Labor Day already so next Monday we will not have the Monday Zoom call certainly we'll have Wednesday this week and Wednesday the following week
but we will not be in office on Monday Labor Day so I hope you guys have a wonderful Labor Day weekend enjoy some time with your family get outdoors have some awesome food and just celebrate so I hope you guys have a good Labor Day weekend
all right have a good day everyone bye bye you're welcome